Prince William and Prince Harry pay
tribute to their late mother Thursday
marks the 20th anniversary of Princess
Diana's death and on Wednesday her son's
visited a memorial garden dedicated to
the iconic royal so like she was on my
small channel beside us
on the eve of Diana's death her son's
came together along with Kate Middleton
to stop by the sunken garden at
Kensington Palace in London William and
Harry braved the rain to view the
grounds that were transformed into a
white garden filled with white flowers
and images of the late Princess of Wales
according to Kensington Palace the chain
symbolizes a way to quote create
peaceful and contemplative spaces where
visitors can reflect on her legacy in
the new NBC documentary Diana 7 days the
prince's recall coping with the loss of
their mom I think one of the hardest
things to come to terms with is the fact
that the people that chased her through
the Institute for the same people that
were taking photographs of her while she
was still dying on the back seat of the
car when you have something so traumatic
is the death of your mother when you're
15 it'll either make or break you and I
wouldn't let it break me
[Music]